pour ce nouveau gentes dames badass il
faut que je vous prévienne de deux
choses la première c'est que notre
histoire se passe exclusivement au 20e
siècle
je sais vous n'en avez pas l'habitude
sur cette chaîne respirer ça va la
deuxième c'est que le personnage auquel
on va s'intéresser était à la fois
féministe et communistes ce qui
multiplie le potentiel de critiques
négatives dans les commentaires par le
nombre de mètres carrés de la place
rouge mais on s'en fout c'est ma chaîne
plus sérieusement le propos de cette
vidéo n'est pas de faire l'apologie de
la montée du parti communiste en france
qu'on en fasse partie ou non ce qui me
concerne c'est non mais en tant
qu'historienne ce qui m'intéresse c'est
de retracer le parcours d'une femme qui
s'est battu pour ses convictions
martha desrumaux était une ouvrière
syndicaliste communiste féministes anti
colonialiste résistante
bref une femme plutôt badass elle né en
à comines dans une famille qui compte
déjà six enfants son père tenait un
cabaret ce qui leur assure un certain
confort de vie dans une ville très
marquée par l'industrialisation des
ouvriers représentait alors 40% de la
population active du nord travaillé sans
sécurité sociale ni allocations chômage
et vivait dans des corons quartiers
pauvres sans eau courante ni électricité
pendant ce temps là pour les familles
riches du nord ça allait les grèves sont
encore très fortement réprimée en cette
fin du 19e siècle celle de 1891 à
fourmies fait sept morts parmi les
manifestants à cause de violences
policières
c'est original mart a grandi dans cette
ambiance de début d'organisation
syndicale cgt est fondée en 1895 et de
nombreux débats ont lieu dans les
cabarets estaminet comme celui que
tenait son père ce dernier leur en 1906
hélas sa famille dans une situation très
précaire ils sont obligés de déménager
et martha doit commencer à travailler à
10 ans alors que l'école était
obligatoire jusque 12 ans à l'époque
mais sur un malentendu ça passait
souvent elles travaillent 9 heures par
jour six jours par semaine pour un
salaire 30 à 50% inférieur à celui des
hommes est encore divisée par deux comme
elle est une enfant face aux conditions
de travail très difficiles dans les
usines textiles de l'époque je pense que
vous connaissez les grandes lignes sans
que j'aie besoin de détailler beaucoup
elle ce syndicat la cgt à l'âge de 13
ans elle ne sait pas lire
elle apprend la politique auprès
d'autres ouvriers et à la guerre au
parti socialiste à la même période
elle subit la première guerre mondiale
de plein fouet la ville de comines étant
évacuée qu'en 1917
en attendant elle doit faire avec
l'occupation allemande
2 le camp de prisonniers russes
installés aux abords de la ville la
destruction de 90% des bâtiments
elle et sa famille sont finalement
envoyé à lyon où elle trouve du travail
dans les ateliers hassebroucq originaire
du nord comme elle de nombreuses
industries et des ménages
au moment de la guerre qui est aussi
l'occasion de nombreuses grèves contre
la hausse des prix et les conditions de
travail
on compte 6 196 grève en 1917 en août
1917 martha participe à sa première
grève pour une augmentation de 5 francs
les femmes sont très nombreuses dans les
usines à cette période du fait de la
guerre toujours mais elle est l'une des
seules à être syndiqués elle est chargée
de diriger la délégation à la préfecture
et demande à ce que les accords soient
lus à voix haute
avant de les signer parce que encore une
fois ne sait toujours pas lire mais elle
ne tire pas ce que ça se sache
elle apprend finalement à lire au début
des années 20 avec une camarade ouvrière
à partir d'une brochure de paul vaillant
couturier
l'un des fondateurs du parti communiste
français et je ne pense pas de cette
phrase puisse être plus de gauche à la
fin des années 20 martha c'est donc lire
et écrire
elle rentre à comines et adhère avec son
frère au parti communiste français
fraîchement créée même si elle n'ose pas
encore participé au débat du parti ou de
la cgt parce qu'elle manque encore
fortement d'éducation politique
et puis on peut supposer un petit
syndrome de l'imposteur typiquement
féminin on sait d'où ça vient elle
continue de mobiliser les ouvrières face
aux conditions de travail de l'usiné
hazebrouck déclarant que les femmes
ouvrières souffre d'une double peine
dans le système capitaliste celle de
l'exploitation par le patronat et la
domination par les hommes militante
féministe dont qui la cause des femmes
restera sa préoccupation principale
durant toute sa vie de militante les
femmes subissaient aussi double tâche de
devoir travailler à l'usiné
parfois une heure à pied de chez elle et
à la maison une fois qu'elle rentrait du
travail lorsqu'elle avait des enfants
elles devaient souvent renoncer à leur
emploi ce qui va demander dépendante du
salaire de leurs maris quand son patron
la nomme contre dame pour essayer de
saper son influence puisque l essence et
du coup surveiller un peu ses collègues
être ensemble ça en une sorte de
délégués du personnel
elle se fait finalement une éducation
politique en 1924 dans une école
léniniste de l'île ce qui lui permet de
s'affirmer davantage par la suite au
sein du pcf elle devient responsable des
femmes dans son secteur
dix des débats des rencontres etc côté
syndicats elle fait aussi partie de la
commission féminine de la cgt et prend
de plus en plus la parole à l'oral lors
des réunions et dans des articles qu'ils
publient dans l'enchaîner elle défend à
plusieurs reprises à travail égal
salaire égal
ce qui n'est pas du tout une cause
encore d'actualité non elle réclame
aussi des congés pré et postnataux de
nombreuses fans faisant des fausses
couches sur le chemin du travail ou à
lézinnes en 1927 elle est invitée dans
la délégation féminine qui part à moscou
pour le dixième anniversaire de la
révolution d'octobre
son départ est un peu compliqué parce
que la préfecture refuse de lui délivrer
un passeport elle doit se faire passer
pour une femme de chambre ait voyagé
sous une fausse identité
les français qui voyagent et vers
l'union soviétique était pisté elle est
découverte en cours de séjour ce qui
complique aussi son retour à moscou où
elle assiste à des réunions où qu'ils
étaient fermés des usines
elle y observe les progrès qu'on les
montre mais gardent une vision critique
sur la condition de vie des ouvrières
elle rentre finalement en france en
passant clandestinement la frontière est
passé mois suivant à témoigner sur ce
qu'elle a vu à moscou elle est aussi élu
au comité central du pcf
toute sa vie est consacrée au
militantisme l'organisent des cagnottes
pour les grèves des années 20 et 30
elle manifeste et grâce à elle une femme
doit être associé à toutes les
directions locale de la cgt
elle repart à moscou en 1931 pour
assister aux écoles internationales
elle y apprend le russe la philosophie
l'économie et retrouve son futur mari
puis mang lina qui est membre de la cgt
eu à marseille en mai 36 ça participe
évidemment aux grèves qui appelle les
congés payés et elle est la seule femme
présente lors de la négociation des
accords matignon avec léon blum à cette
époque elle apparaît aussi dans le film
la vie est à nous de jean renoir qui
montre la vie quotidienne des français
ouvriers paysans et bonjour dans cette
atmosphère de victoire elle a un fils en
1937 et épouse louis - guînes le père un
an plus tard mais ses activités
militantes ne sont jamais loin
en 1938 la seconde guerre mondiale se
profile elle participe à l'évacuation
des enfants espagnols dans le contexte
de la guerre civile mais souffre d'une
forte communication anti communiste à
partir de la signature des accords
germano soviétique
le pcf est dissoute en 1939 et louis
mang lina mobilisés
avant d'être dissous le parti avait
demandé à ses membres qu'il repère
discrètement des planques et loue des
appartements en vue de la guerre c'est
donc tout naturellement que martha
pascal unis tentent à résistante elle
organise le passage clandestin de
maurice thorez à moscou et est chargée
des communications entre lille et
bruxelles
les résistants du nord imprime
clandestinement l'enchaîner qui avait
été interdite récupère des arbres et
continue les grèves au sein des usines
malgré l'occupation allemande
ils font aussi tout leur possible pour
freiner la production en sabotant les
voies ferrées et en détruisant des
pylones électriques les écluses les
péniches
né en réaction de nombreux ouvriers sont
arrêtés et déportés
tout s'accélère en outre 41 le 26 août
trois communistes à takara gaffé
réservés aux officiers allemands il en
tue 2 et en blesse un troisième en
réaction de quoi les autorités
allemandes demandent au préfet une liste
de dirigeants communistes parmi lesquels
se trouve le nom de marta mangue in
heureusement pour elle elle n'est pas
cité en tant que martha desrumaux et à
parvient à garder son secret parce que
ça lui elle aurait sûrement valu
beaucoup plus de problèmes
elle est emprisonnée pendant quatre mois
à la prison de loos pendant que d'autres
militants sont directement fusillés puis
embarqué dans un train en direction de
bruxelles liège aix la chapelle alors
hambourg et finalement ravate boucle
ravas bouquet l'un des nombreux camps de
concentration mais en place par le
régime nazi est l'un des seuls réservé
aux fins après la libération martin
rédigé un long texte expliquant ces
conditions de vie dans les camps je vais
pas m'étendre dessus parce que je pense
que l'on sorte connaissais déjà pas mal
de détails
si vous avez suivi des cours d'histoire
dans le secondaire mais en voici
quelques extraits dont les premiers
peuvent choquer donc si vous êtes plutôt
sensible passé à ce talent code ici les
horaires étaient souvent bousculé en
particulier à cause des appels qui
paraissait interminable et qui en fait
durer parfois plusieurs heures ce qui
était particulièrement pénible par temps
froid pour des êtres sous alimentés
dans ces conditions les évanouissements
étaient fréquents parfois aussi quand on
voulait se couvrir celle qui venait de
s'écrouler constaté qu'il était trop
tard elle était morte
un jour d'août 1942 on prenne pas parmi
les polonaises 74 jeunes filles aussi
saine que possible les infirmières
tchèque polonaise qui étaient envoyés
racontèrent ce qu'elle vire à certains
produits étaient introduits dans les
jambes des patientes
le lendemain on ouvrait les jambes et
l'on prélevait os ou mouël cette jeune
fille mourir au cours de l'opération
dix autres furent fusillés juste après
il semble que les allemands aient voulu
faire disparaître toute trace de cette
expérience car le reste des jeunes
filles condamnées à mort passe à dans le
bloc des martres hummel marfa raconte
encore d'autres expériences médicales
les personnages et gaz et le travail
forcé la violence le manque
d'alimentation et d'hygiène la
solidarité qui se met en place
aussi la résistance telle que nous la
comprenons alors prenez toutes les
formes capable de soutenir le physique
et le moral des détenus et d'affaiblir
le potentiel de guerre de l'allemagne
donc nous pratiquions à la fois entraide
soutien propagande des sabotages
chapardage vol
les polonaises régné à la cuisine vous
avez institué une sorte de rationnement
volontaires en faveur des plus jeunes et
des malades notre groupe était
spécialisée dans le détournement des
pull-overs et du linge la plupart des
infirmières et des tchèques
l'une d'entre elles avait accès aux
cartes et sauva la vie à bien des
camarades de la façon suivante
en effet chaque détenu avait une fiche
individuelle lorsque par suite de
maladie ou d'épuisement une femme
étaient reconnues inaptes au travail où
il établissait une carte rose ce qui
équivalait à un arrêt de mort à brève
échéance
elsa dolan sq a subtilisé alors les
cartes roses et les remplacer dans la
mesure du possible par des cartes jaunes
marta est d'ailleurs sauvé par ce même
procédé suite à une infection de la main
le 1er avril 1945 elle est enfin libéré
parmi 300 femmes choisies pour un
échange avec des femmes est seize
détenus en france
elle arrive à paris le 14 avril dans un
train attendu par le général de gaulle
et qui choisit finalement de ne pas
faire de discours en constatant l'état
d'épuisement de la plupart des femmes
martin ne tarde pas à témoigner de son
expérience à la radio d'abord puis de
retour à lille étant la première femme
lilloise à revenir dès quand elle
retrouve rapidement ses activités
qu'elle continue de mener jusqu'à sa
mort en
1982 elle codirige la direction
départementale du pcf est adjointe à la
mairie de lille retrouve ses mandats à
la cgt elle continue de s'exprimer
régulièrement sur la place des femmes et
de les encourager à se battre pour leurs
droits
elle ne quitte pas non plus le milieu
ouvrier puisqu'elle passe la fin de sa
vie dans le quartier de wazemmes se
trouvaient encore de nombreux ateliers
et usines depuis sa mort son nom est
resté peu connue du grand public elle
n'était qu'une femme issues du milieu
ouvrier très grande pas particulièrement
belle souvent la seule femme dans les
groupes qu'elle fréquente mais pas assez
mise au premier plan
pourtant sa mémoire demeure plusieurs
rues portent son nom c'est qu'un collège
lillois
depuis plusieurs années l'association
des amis de martha desrumaux milite pour
qu'elle entre au panthéon en 2013
françois hollande avait proposé qu'une
nouvelle famille est entrée elle aurait
été la première femme ouvrière à y
opposer
lasnier finalement pas entrer mais
j'espère que cette vidéo contribuera à
la faire connaître
si vous voulez plus d'informations vous
pouvez vous rapprocher de l'association
que j'ai incité dont je mettrai des
liens en commentaire c'est d'ailleurs
grâce aux livres publiés par cette
association que j'ai écrit cet épisode
après avoir découvert martin lors d'une
conférence j'espère que vous avez
apprécié cette vidéo très éloigné les
époques que j'aborde habituellement mais
sur une femme tellement bad ass et à
bientôt
m
[Musique]